we have every first move against one E4
that's by Tess as Bobby Fischer says
tiered and ranked here it is okay so we
start with E4 everything's all cool you
waiting to see your E5 is Sicilian you
know what I mean even the Carroll Khan
and then they come out with this move
right here B5
it's gonna be a long day at the office
this is actually called The Hang upon
for no reason opening in fact after B5
this is a very very terrible move all we
do is take the pawn and we're done
basically developing pieces take the
whole Center B5 is not a move let's move
to the next one coming in at number 19
here's the next one after E4 they go
F5 are you kidding me
first off find gold trip and of course
you do not push the F Pawn don't play F6
or F3 as fine gold says secondly you
just open up the king with a lot of
problems after Pawn takes at five but
you should always take this Pawn you're
already threading Queen H5 check and
after G6 Pawn takes G6 is next this is
called the Doris Gambit or the Doris
opening very very bad here E4 F5 you
just take that let's move to the next
one coming in at number 18 we have the
Barnes opening what is that well let's
check it out after E4 the move is F6
just as bad as F5 okay maybe not as
terrible but it's still pretty terrible
again fine gold doesn't like you pushing
those F pawns so don't do it secondly
right it isn't as terrible as you think
it is but it is pretty bad nevertheless
the King has just opened up for no
reason here the Knight wanted to go to
F6 now the Pawn's there but what we do
is right here we're just gonna develop
D4 Knight to F3 Knight to C3 you can
even grab lots of space if you like with
the four pawns type of attack that
you'll see in many different openings D4
F4 C4 put the knights behind the pawns
really clear and easy development here
but you can't punish this move right now
immediately F6 is very bad though the
Knight cannot go to F6 and there's gonna
be lots of problems this one's called
the Barnes opening don't try this one at
home now let's move to the next one and
here we are with the next one after move
one E4 they go A5 what are you doing
with your life this one is called the
wear defense so be very aware of how bad
this opening is after A5 of course this
is just rough they a lot of times
believe it or not they're going to play
Rook A6 next and you just take it what
are you doing right this is a very very
bad move all we do again is center right
of course they say a uh move on the
flank should be countered with with a
move in the center right so any play on
the wing should be countered with a play
in the center so D4 is good C4 F4 once
again they're not taking a center so you
should maybe Knight to F3 Knight C3 uh
Bishop to C4 and Etc we just draw many
the arrows here just to show your plans
and ideas but again this is a bad move
doesn't do anything for the sensor at
all and looking to develop the move uh
The Rook in a very very bad Fashion
After Bishop takes A6 this is called the
wear defense speed very aware and stay
away from this one let's move to the
next here we go with the next one after
move one E4 they go H5 what are you
doing with your life once again this one
is called the Goldsmith opening
something crazy what the heck is that
Goldsmith who is Goldsmith the Goldsmith
defense and this one is just as bad but
of course at least you know with the
pawn not on D4 then they can play Rook
H6 and try to do the weird Rook lift and
you will see this weird stuff but it's
just going to be a clumsy rook and very
vulnerable to attack and being trapped
in ETC H5 is a very bad move what do we
do with play on the wing should be
countered with pause the video if you
remember that
play in the center what do we do D4
Knight to C3 you can go C4 F4 all the
same moves we pointed out before because
they did nothing in the center this is
why H5 is not the best move okay we got
E4 H5 this is another one let's move to
the next next up against 184 we have E4
eight six
well this one is called the car defense
in fact the c-a-r-r and it seems like
that they don't car about anything in
life after this move A6 oh this is
ridiculous right play on the wing should
be countered with we've said this many
times before play in the center
absolutely so playing something like B4
H6 could be a nice inclusion later on a
lot of times you may see this in
openings that you actually play
um all the time like deep openings and
all the Deep Theory H6 is could be a a
nice prophylactic move or useful move
later on but right now in the beginning
doesn't do much for the sensor so we can
again take the whole thing with the D4
maybe C4 to F4 or Knight F3 Knight C3
however you want to do it very nice ways
to play this but H6 is not one of them
let's move to the next next up we have
against one E4 we have Knight H6 very
strange now of course it develops peace
but it's still a night on the edge of
board they say Knight on the rim is dim
or Grim or however you want to spell it
or rhyme it the Knight on the edge of
the board is not the best place as it
cuts off many squares this one's
actually called The Hippopotamus which
is actually different because of course
A lot of times you'll see with a regular
hippo with black or white you put the
Bishops or your fing cattle the Bishops
on G7 and B7 you put all the pawns on
like the six rank like E6 D6 B6 G shakes
h6a6 right everything on like six right
most of them except the uh the F and C
pawns usually um and then you're just
gonna have to you know springboard your
position later on Knights go to D7 and
E7 but here on Knight H6 it's a little
bit strange here definitely not the move
that you should be playing the knight's
already restricted you can't even go
anywhere and you might have to play
something like F6 Knight F7 here very
strange very playable but very strange
at the same time I'll take white all day
here all we do is again develop the
pieces you see a pattern here everything
that we've seen so far is kind of like
the same when it comes to our you know
objective is to make sure we take over
the center and develop our pieces and
Etc this is the hippopotamus let's move
on to the next one next up we have after
E4 Knight A6 ooh looks just like the
hippo but it's the other side of the
board board this one's called the
lemming defense or the lemon line
because of how sour this one gonna be
for the black pieces okay same plan
what's the plan pause the video if you
need to but you should know that by now
right play on the wing should be
countered by sounds like a broken record
at this point right is uh playing a
center do the same stuff they're not
taking a center so we're gonna take it
what is Knight A6 it's a really bad move
is what it is night on the rim is them
as we mentioned before okay here we go
that one's done now let's move to the
next next up against one E4 or one of
these crazy tries right you're gonna see
this in your games today is G5 what is
this well this one's called the board
who came up with that one well actually
it's in Reverse if you're learning
something today what do you mean in
Reverse well if you go G4 move one right
so if we back up here and we go G4 this
is actually called the grab opening but
if you go E4 G5 it's inverse so it's
called the Borg opening this is
ridiculous okay this is not a good
opening at all what do you do right at
the this point you should actually know
what we're going to do with our pieces
based off of the other openings we've
already seen after G5 here what do you
think it would do here pause the video
if you need some time
but of course we take the center
something like B4 once again let's make
the move on the board Bishop takes G5 is
now available we also have C3 we can
play C4 next now F4 probably not the
greatest in this situation and Knight F3
can run into G4 but we can't attack this
Pawn already we can even set up a center
this way put the Bishops on D3 and E3
maybe the knights here too as well
nevertheless we have a great position G5
is really really bad out of the opening
now let's move to the next one okay here
we are with the next reply after e41 E4
one A6 another flank move what is this
now actually believe it or not this one
was actually played by Anthony Tony
miles and he beat karpov believe it or
not right so this is playable but it is
one of those don't try this at home guys
just I mean you can try it and if you
lose 10 games out of 11 that's okay it's
most likely a lot of it has to do with
this move right here in the beginning of
course maybe you need to take some
Central squares once again so our plan
stays the same right is what D4 Knight
F3 maybe F4 you can even let me go for a
fin Kettle route if you like but of
course just principal chest D4 and
Knight F3 C4 maybe even F4 once again
develop your pieces and take the whole
Center and put the pieces around it
because black failed to take any type of
Center here making a wing move which is
countered by Center in the beginning of
the game E4 A6 right this one's actually
called the Saint George defense right St
George it is and Tony miles usually
gonna be carp off this was a cool one of
course playable sometimes very rare but
uh not the greatest move and again don't
try this one at your house okay here it
is now let's move to the next one okay
here we are with our next reply to 1e4
it's B6 now this one actually isn't as
bad as the other options here right so
this one's actually called the Owens
defense and the the goal here is
actually put the bishop on B7 play
something like E6 so you have a French
type of structure with the pawn on E6
and a Pawn on B6 you actually use your
Bishops in fact this is like a reverse
B3 Larson system that is B3 move one
right it's a it's actually just in
Reverse we play B3 Bishop to B2 lots of
times play E3 and Bishop B5 and try to
pin the Knight and actually use a lot of
uh use the pieces to play in the center
pieces and Pawns in fact so I have to
move one E4 B6 Black's gonna do the same
thing at some point right with uh with
playing E6 maybe try to pin our Knight
if we play C3 play C5 and put the bishop
on B7 this was the Owens defense not
played as much and of course it is a
nice try so just to throw people off on
it for Theory wise and off of things
that they're used to White that is of
course by playing one and B6 and Bishop
B7 white usually doesn't play against
this setup too much and it is a very
stable setup and you can play it and it
looks like a French defense in many ways
with E6 so it is something you can try
at home but it is slightly passive
because it does nothing in the center so
you need to definitely pay attention to
this if you're playing it from the black
side you need to pay attention and make
sure that you are doing central moves
very quickly C5 D6 E6 Knight F6
Etc Knight to C6 or D7 in many cases too
as well Knight F6 moving the bishop out
but white is going to do many things
very easily same thing right especially
if you don't take the center then we're
going to play moves like D4 right
immediately take this whole Center
ourselves Bishop to D3 as a move F4
there's lots of place ways you can play
this as well this one's the Owens
defense I've known just a little bit
more and we'll move to the next one
right now next stuff in response to one
E4 we have Knight to C6 unorthodox very
unorthodox this one is called the nimsu
which uh defense in fact by Aaron
nimswitch so this one actually is very
very strange right now you also can
transpose into many different openings
after Knight F3 you can play E5
immediately which transposed into an e45
opening we just don't know which one yet
you can go Bishop C4 of course Italian
game you can also go at Roy Lopez as
well so it's very important to
understand transpositions but after
Knight C6 even after the D4 moves as a
D5 and you do want to know what you're
doing Pawn takes leads to some trouble
with the D4 Pawn E5 leads to Bishop F5
and the bishop does go out come out very
quickly and sometimes you can see a
night before that you'll see in Reverse
of Joe Bob of London um and many London
type structures so it's definitely
difficult and also black has two pieces
out we don't have any out yet but we do
have the the sensor here so very
interesting opening something to pay
attention to honestly from both colors
something that you should know it's
called the NIMS which the defense
something a little bit different and
then unorthodox and a lot of times
unorthodox can throw your opponent off
from the black side but from y here
white standpoint you just develop your
pieces once again you should know a
little bit of theory and just obviously
develop your pieces very easy
fundamental chest right E5 after Knight
F3 we play D4 we play Knight to C3 you
can play Bishop D3 Bishop B5 or castling
once again very nice stuff get your
pieces out play great chess and now
we'll move to the next next up in
response to one E4 we have Knight F6
that one's played quite often believe it
or not this one's actually called in the
American way the alkyne but of course
the iliac and as well is how you uh
could say it or pronounce it probably
still saying that wrong but it is of
course from um Alexander aliakin right
so Knight F6 this is actually a very
very interesting opening it's very
provocative to say the the lease here
because we're going to push on the
Knight most times here if you don't then
they can play moves like D5 and other
things but E5 attacks the Knight Knight
F6 and after Knight to D5 you can
actually play something like C4 or D4 or
you know C4 D4 F4 four pawn attack you
can go Knight F3 you can go Bishop C4
very flexible way of doing this this is
not recommended to try at home now Bobby
Fischer did actually win only one world
championship game with this and there's
a reason why there's only one game in
the world championship with this opening
from the black side here because you got
to be careful right it's very
provocative you get lots of space I mean
even just looking at how scary this
could be from the black side after a
move I even C4 first Knight P6 and then
D4 and then D6 you can go F4 two as well
like look at all these pods like what is
going hey man relax well I'm not you
play Knight F6 move one you gave me all
these Tempe and you're able you know I'm
able to take the center so I'm going to
take the center this one is the aliacin
or the alkyne of course something to pay
attention to always push on the Knight
always push on the night when you face
this again let's move to the next one
here we go with our next response to one
E4 and this one you gotta be careful
with this one's called the Scandinavian
D5 oh my goodness now all the scandi
people in the YouTube all the scandi
world this team scandies the John
Bartholomew Hong man here we go okay
look first off you can try this at home
but I mean if you get hurt right you
know touch the stove if it's hot right
you know you know it's gonna burn it's
gonna hurt right that's what you have
here with the Scandinavian now it's very
playable it is played it actually was
played many times by even strong uh
world champions after he takes D5 Queen
takes D5 now you also have the Knight of
six versions as well which are more calm
but Queen takes D5 is the usual stuff
and you just get an all-out attack this
is not the greatest opening from the
black side here but of course you do get
lots of Tempe and it is again
provocative just like you would see in
the alicant right so okay Knight to C3
hits the queen queen can go to d8 or A5
right usually you follow up with the D4
let's just go down the rabbit hole here
D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 C6 right and
Bishop to C4 Bishop D3 Bishop E2 is a
move Bishop D2 is a move all these are
moves you play 95. they actually just
get lots of space and you actually have
a very good spatial Advantage here
you're also trying to attack black many
times for and trying to punish them for
bringing the queen out very early it's
very playable for both sides of
Scandinavian provocative opening and
white can get lots of attacking fun
chances so not anything to be afraid of
from the white side at all right this is
a Scandinavian definitely pay attention
to this one I have this one on your
radar let's move to the next one here we
go with our next reply to one E4 it is
G6 the modern defense now this one is
modern you can actually play it today it
is not refuted it is something you can
play from the black side now you do give
up the center a lot and there's lots of
ways that white can attack black now you
have to understand when you do give up
the center with wing pawn moves like
this you you have to understand that you
will come under some fire you will have
less space sometimes you have to play
dynamic because you gave up so much
space you have to make moves very
quickly meaning uh do things very
quickly C5 and pawn breaks E6 D5 look
for tactics and imbalances dynamicism
and there's a reason why Hikaru Nakamura
actually used this many times with great
success it doesn't matter what he plays
obviously but of course the modern was
one thing that he used many many times
in title Tuesday if you ask him in fact
on his stream he says that he likes the
imbalances that it gives so it always is
like fighting yes I'm giving up
something space and you know an attack
for white many in many cases but I have
some imbalances and if you make that
mistake which is most point you know he
car was gonna clamp on that and figure
that out you're going to lose you're
going to have some problems here um from
the white side now the modern is
definitely modern way to play it is very
playable but that doesn't mean you're
going to get the same results as Hikaru
but you can play the opening that he has
played E6 G6 D4 this G7 many times
Knight F3 you go D6 A6 stuff like that
C4 and ic3
you can go Bishop E3 you can go H3 I
mean there's many ways you can play this
but this one's called the modern defense
and in modern day at times it's still
playable from both sides I would
personally choose white but definitely a
playable move this one's the modern
defense let's move to the next next up
on our list we have the perk defense of
course right it like perk out he said
okay American perk right but pirc is
actually pronounced Pierce p-e-r-t-s
right or Z and but it's pronounce the
Pierce actually which is D6 E4 D6 right
park Pierce same thing E4 D6 this is a
very solid move it can actually run into
the Philadelphia or many other openings
Believe It or Not sometimes even Kings
Indians right it just depends on what's
going on but definitely a very flexible
move and after you play A Move Like You
D4 they go Knight F6 and then Knight C3
and you kind of have what they call like
the king's Indian for E4 against E4
right now of course they didn't go C4
here so it's not King's Indian like but
it's kind of King's Indian like so if
you do like a king's Indian defense it
is something to pay attention to from
the black side and maybe you can
actually add it to your repertoire white
of course is going to play moves like
Bishop to E3 maybe play Queen D2 F3 and
try to go for a a king side Onslaught
and try to mate on this side of the
board as you will see in the Yugoslav
variation of the Dragon Sicilian right
so you can see this a lot and it does
resemble sort of a dragon type system
but C5 has not been played now C5 can be
played and this can actually transpose
into a um a dragon Cecilia in many ways
but of course it is based off the move
order this one's the perk or the Pierce
defense is very cool of course very fun
opening now let's move to our next all
right here we go with our next move in
response to one E4 this one is the
French defense okay well you French fans
out there actually grew up on this
opening got over like 1800 OTB with
facing move to E5 and then C5 but E6
French is very solid the bad thing about
the French is that this light Square
Bishop gets locked in many times and
this is the only real problem in the
fridge after D4 D5 you can have many
ways to go Knight C3 is more aggressive
E5 grabs a lot of space F3 is definitely
not a move but it has played before
Bishop D3 more of the selector variation
Knight to D2 to rash type variations as
well E5 is more standard to it so it's
just a advanced variation played a lot
but if you've noticed how this bishop is
locked inside apology when whites are
free range to do whatever they want lots
of times the bishop goes to D3 and if
there's a castle there's almost some big
big sacking possibilities on H7 they
have to be very very careful here from
the black side because of the setup of
the passive Bishop the pawn chain right
always Pawn structures or Pawn
structures are like the skeleton of the
position and it tells you what you
should be doing so of course the the way
that the pawn structure points is in the
direction that you should be playing in
so lots of times as you see here even
with the pawn on C3 C5 C3 right Black's
gonna play more on the queen side
Etc stuff like this A6 and white is
going to play more on the king side I
have three Bishop D3 castling sometimes
even sacrific single H7 if you Castle
early because the bishop is not able to
come to F5 you put a knight on G5 you
play Queen H5 and there's mates many
possible mates here and many times right
so this was a French defense very solid
opening in fact played uh for the likes
of really lots of strong players lots of
GMS and it's definitely playable in
today's time so this is the French
defense and now let's move to our next
one here we go with our next reply the
last few here is E4 and C6 now this one
is what they call the Carroll Khan right
very strong very solid opening lots of
players use this one there's lots of
flexibility and dynamicism if people
want to actually mix up the game and
fight for more the better part this is
kind of the cousin of the French right
after D4 and we see reason why it's a
cousin here is in the French after E6
The Bishop's locked in but this is why
we go C6 to lock the bishop outside of
the pawn chain and not inside right or
even playing Knight F3 here and not
allowing the bishop to be locked in on
C8 like you would see in the French
defense this one's different very solid
Dynamic and lots of players play this
one from beginner all the way to Super
GM this is definitely a very solid
opening very strong and from both sides
there's always play in the Carroll Khan
recommended you study from both sides so
you can learn lots of things about it
this one's a Carroll Khan let's move to
the next one here we are with our next
one can you guess what it is can you
guess what it is what do you think it is
pause the video which one do you think
this one is
it is E5 symmetrical right symmetrical
very very easy to play you see this all
the time right after white plays E4
black says I'm going to play E5 and do
the same thing as you yes I'm a temple
down and I have to respond to things
that you do for instance negative three
we have to respond to Knights ac5 so
Knight C6 but I developed two as well
and I'm saying I have my fair share in
the center as well very strong can play
all the way up to the classics all the
way up to the history of Chess this move
has been played one of the strongest
moves right behind the number one one
that we're going to look at in a few
here but at E5 is definitely very strong
you can go many ways from here D6
obviously you can go fill the doors I
mean it's so many options pets are off
after night of six Knight or the Russian
Knight F3 Knight of six so many things
that you can do here guys so very very
strong it's good to understand what you
have and it's a very good move and it's
not being refuted anytime soon in the
history of Chess okay that's E4 E5 now
let's move to our final move against one
E4 okay guys last response to one E4 can
you guess it can you guess it 100 ELO to
anybody that can guess this move right
here okay ELO is sold separately but
after E4 the move is
C5 the Sicilian the most combative
response to E4 now I like to play this
from both sides many players do E4 you
know aggressive E4 Best Buy tests lots
of open lines and diagonals and C5 right
very combative black says yeah I have my
own plans I know you want to do your
thing and play aggressive and play E4
I'm gonna do my thing as well most
combative response is C5 the Sicilian is
so many different Sicilians so
theoretical so many so much this so much
that it's very fun fun chest and you're
gonna see a lot of that hopefully you're
on the fun side of the fun shots here
but this is the Cecilia defense you have
so many of them right Knight F3 can be a
move a favorite of mine is to see
Theresa seal for the kill or the C3
Sicilian playing C3 you can play Smith
Mora D4 you can play F4 strain system
you can play G3 Knight F3 and only a
contrary of course maybe even open
Sicilian here you can play D6 more night
orb or classicals to sell you have
Knight to C6 we can play even
accelerated dragons or rosalimos you can
play G6 here accelerated dragon E6 time
another so many Sicilians like 20 30
they even make up Sicilians now in this
day and time right the Sicilian Defense
is one of the most studied openings of
course besides e52 as well but one of
the most fun and combative ones
hopefully you're feeling combative and
you study some of that from both sides
today or tomorrow or in your chest
career hopefully it works for you but
these were the responses to one E4
hopefully you enjoyed today's video and
if you did then check the videos right
after this one and we'll see you on the
next one